what's reasonable disruption depends on
the context
when you've got an event like this that
is a once in a generation event
and you'll have hundreds of thousands of
people close by looking to observe it
um millions and millions of people
watching it
um
disrupting that it's a different context
isn't it so that's why uh our assessment
of the Tipping Point to say this protest
has gone beyond the reasonable inter
being disruptive and therefore we're
going to intervene it's a much lower
tolerance than it might be on a normal
day and this is an immense operation in
fact tomorrow Saturday it'd be the
biggest single deployment we've done in
London ever for this operation there'll
be well over eleven and a half thousand
officers involved what the public will
see will be that visible front layer of
officers stood in in sort of dignified
ceremonial way but behind that there are
layers of officers working covertly
observing from different places there's
been intelligence effort it's a lot for
people who want to spoil the event and
then behind that we've got some
fantastic colleagues largely staff
colleagues doing immense Logistics work
because feeding all these people and
housing all these people is massive so
it's been a tremendous operation and we
are doing everything we possibly can do
to provide a safe secure and dignified
event the coronation